board of trustees moved to table a
planned vote on a hybrid learning model
tonight
citing the recent kobit 19 spike in
clark county
while some are for the weight others
worry time away from the classroom
is really hurting our kids sasha loftis
joins us live from ccsd headquarters
with more on what families are saying
tonight sasha
denise and brian the parents i spoke
with tonight say distance learning has
really been tough but they don't want to
rush this decision
now some trustees were against the
decision to postpone tonight but the
majority
said they believed it's best to keep
kids home as our coveted numbers spike
i think they did the right thing by
tabling the discussion
parents jeffrey and emily balcom share
their thoughts on the latest
clark county school district discussion
so i want families and students to know
that i recognize their struggles but i
also recognize this decision
is too important to rush in thursday's
virtual meeting
ccsd leaders postponed a vote to
transition to hybrid learning
citing a recent spike in covet 19
numbers
we need to have a plan where people
are volunteering to go in without
worrying about
losing their lives the 205 page plan
would have gone into effect in january
but with the governor's latest
suggestion to stay home
that vote was tabled until further
notice there is more work to be done
and if this board's inability to make a
decision
has now hampered that we are hurting our
children
even more while it's clear some are
against the plan to postpone
the balcom say now is not the time to
make a definite decision we couldn't
make a decision as parents
because we don't know what as dr jarrah
said tonight he doesn't have a crystal
ball
they say they're willing to hold off
until they know
their kids are safe i think the best
decision for
for parents and families and teachers is
going to end up being
the most informed decision and we have
to wait
the trustees did not decide on a future
date for a vote when it comes to
hybrid learning or bringing the kids
back to the classroom in any capacity
of course stay with eight news now for
the latest on this as it develops
for that reporting live sasha loftis 8
news now